foreign
she became involved in suspected
criminal activity started using meth a
few months ago she made it painfully
clear that she wants nothing to do with
any biological family or lifetime
friends um
tell that you love your sister
[Music]
Brass Monkey the funky monkey
Brass Monkey junkie dude licensed what a
record hey welcome to Dr John deloney
show I'm John I'll be your host
so is that what I is that I'm not really
a host
then what are yeah what are you
the list of answers to that question is
long I know mostly inappropriate
what would you be called if you were not
the host
I don't know I guess I'm the host I
think that's what I am the host of the
The Dr John deloney show and I'm John
it's good to meet you this this is an
incredible show and if you're new to us
I apologize not really it's kind of off
the rails hey this is the greatest
mental health and marriage and parenting
podcast of all time and this is the last
show we're shooting before we take a
short holiday break and so you're
hearing this after the holidays after
the New Year you are already into your
workout program you've already thought
about quitting you've already seen that
plate of donuts and you're like
hey let's just do it but don't but
you're not you haven't yet yeah but for
us we're about to take a break and I am
totally fried everybody is Ben's just
got his head on the board he's drooling
Jenna's asleep over there Kelly she's
hasn't stopped drinking since like four
days ago
she's just in It to Win It
oh man Christian's just staring off into
space back there he's just he's I don't
know what day it is and and Andrew
Andrew actually is plugged in
because I think you're part robot but
hey we're we're so glad that you've
joined us for this this uh last episode
for a minute
um for you though on the feed it'll be
back uh on Monday or on Wednesday
whenever this thing comes out the feed's
not gonna change for you
probably I'm done talking is that right
I I think you should
Fort Wayne listen to Kelly just
producing the show like like a
like a producer what's up Bethany
hi how's it going good how are you
yeah going oh yeah
oh man what's up
um well I am calling because
um my husband and I had well mostly me
I've had issues with intimacy like since
we've been married and married for
almost five years and it's just like
kind of a cycle of I get I work really
hard and it's going good for a month or
two and then life happens and there's
something big happens and then I have to
start all over again afterwards and I'm
kind of sick of it I want to know how to
end the cycle yeah no kidding so
man a couple things you said are
heartbreaking and this is me not at you
but me with you
um
so hey I want to make sure we're we're
saying the same things when you talk
about intimacy you're talking about
having sex and you're talking about just
the whole environment around sex in your
house
um I guess
or tell me I'm wrong what do you mean by
intimacy
um yeah mostly six okay okay
um and you say it's a it's a cycle what
is tell me more about that and um talk
directly into your phone I can uh having
a little bit of trouble hearing you
um what do you mean when you say cycle
well
like before I got married I'd been
almost engaged with somebody else and
they're
had been some boundary issues there and
it took me a while to get over those and
actually
get to wear physical
into touch and other things were
kind of enjoyable
and then when you say boundary issues
were you sexually assaulted
um not necessarily assaulted but like I
I never verbally said no and it was
nothing more than like french kissing
but I didn't want it and he didn't
respond to any physical cues that I was
sending
so that was your first time you were in
a situation where you felt out of
control of your own body
yes okay all right and did you have
abuse in your in your own personal
perspect when you were a kid
no okay all right so fast forward to now
then you get married and
[Music]
it's tell me about this cycle
so that took me a lot of work through my
husband is great he one of those reasons
why I fell in love with him so fast is
because he always asks before everything
um he's a consent guy
oh yeah he's fantastic yeah
um
but I worked through all those issues I
read a lot of books I went to some
therapy I did some ambr
and
it got a lot better and then like I
can't remember what happened but I'd
have a season of depression and then
like something else would crop up that
affected intimacy negatively for me and
it just like every time
I get good at it then something would
happen
like we'd have to move or I'd have a kid
and into the pause after you have a kid
and it'd take me forever to get back
into it and I'd have to work through
different things but I have to work all
over again
some of what you're describing is normal
life
yeah like you have a kid and then
everything's a disaster
all across I mean everything's a
disaster right meal time is a disaster
sex is a disaster you're like your body
is not your own right I mean so there's
there that adjustment period is natural
can I ask you a question and tell me I'm
if I'm off base okay
okay
does somebody tell you sex is really bad
foreign up
but
because your body sounds like it has a
response to it it's not a safe place
intimacy and connection in an ideal
world is a place where
you can go be fully yourself because
there's nowhere to hide right
yeah you heard that like Let your freak
flag fly or that it's where you
literally have no clothes on in front of
somebody else right and there's nowhere
else to hide so I'm gonna be fully me
and everywhere else I have to perform I
have to perform at work I have to
perform at my in-laws house I got to
perform at my parents house I got to
perform with my kids at school
but behind closed doors with somebody
that like I am
I have I'm handing all my trust to
man we can get off the rails it's a
place of Safety and Security and for
your body it is not it's the opposite
where does that come from
[Music]
probably
it's just I don't know
being that vulnerable is really scary
why is that scary like why does your
body go go into neutral or go to
shutdown when
um you're being vulnerable because that
would tell me that it doesn't only just
happen with sex and intimacy it happens
when your husband gets frustrated or
when you get mad or when you suffer a
loss or heartbreak your body does very
similar things is that right
yeah I think so okay
where did your body learn that the best
your best bet the best way to keep you
safe was to disappear
was to shut it down
not being good enough
who told you you weren't good enough
I don't think my family did but I mean
it's a really big family
probably myself honestly
sometimes our families tell us things
that
plant seeds within us that bloom later
on into really gnarly Thorn bushes that
make life really hard
and sometimes they plant No Seeds
so we look up and we're 25 or we're 30
and we have our own kids and there is
there's no fruit to draw on there's
nothing
and you can
absorb the story
that you're not even worth taught
telling a story to
and then that becomes the story you tell
yourself which is you're not enough or
you're not gonna do this right or you're
going to screw up or somebody else is
going to be disappointed and and and
then that guy who you love
is like hey want to do it
and your body goes into well I could
fail I could screw this up I could not
be enough for him I could fill in the
blank is that fair
yeah that's about right okay so here's
the challenge that I I'm hearing
there's two there's two con conflicting
things happening one is this depression
that's haunted you for a long time
and you're trying to heal it
episodically meaning I want to not feel
this particular way about a particular
thing
so it's kind of like your house is on
fire and every time the Smoke Gets In
Your particular room you turn on a fan
to blow the Smoke Out
and you're trying to figure out where
the Smoke's coming from so you can blow
the smoke out when really what we need
to do is put the fire out
you get what I'm saying
um
so the the EMDR is trauma-based and so
if that was around your previous
boyfriend taking advantage of you or not
not respecting about or not responding
to your cues
um and then the resulting guilt and
shame all that stuff that comes from
feeling like your body is not your own
right when somebody steals that from you
um
EMDR is good for that moment the broader
conversation is sitting with a therapist
and a counselor and talking about the
generalized depression the bigger
picture my body has learned over time
your story doesn't matter you just need
to disappear and what we need to do is
over time teach that body nope I've got
needs I want to live a fun wild Reckless
exciting fun adventures of a life
because it's short and it goes by really
really fast and I want I want to take
everything from it I can and I want to
give everything I can
um and so we're going to have to train
our body over time about that that's one
thing the other thing is just the
natural ups and downs of
being sexually intimate with somebody
over a long period of time
because there's babies and there's kids
and then there's work deadlines and
there's travel and then there's gain 30
pounds and then there's lost 40 pounds
and then there's wrinkles and then
there's remember that time and we used
to and now we don't need more and hey
you need to get testosterone and then
you need to get hormone therapy here but
there's just that the nature of it and
so what I am seeing across the country
is people shifting from a it's always
going to be on fire which isn't true two
it can be pretty hot talking about where
we are right now
and discovering hey you're into this
these days and you don't like this
anymore but you used to you don't like
this anymore and you want to try this
and have you thought about this and
that's a whole new level of intimacy
does that make sense
yeah so it's it's more about taking that
negativity that you feel surrounding
like I always had a baby we haven't it's
actually intimate in a long time I can
tell my husband's getting frustrated I'm
getting frustrated
but then my body tenses up and it goes
to war every time we try something and
it's uncomfortable and it's awkward it's
there that we're going to lean into that
and turn that into a moment of intimacy
in and of itself talking about it
laughing about it being silly about it
trying and then stopping and stopping
and trying we're gonna make that not
something to run and hide from but we're
going to make that the focus is that is
that is that ringing a bell
yeah okay thank you I have a question
we'll see just I've been through therapy
off and on for the last three years okay
and I only stopped when I feel
like like I can handle it and then I end
up having to go back how do I know when
like it's actually processed or do I
when your body doesn't take off on you
here here's the the best way I can
explain it is
um
and you can read about this in the what
the book that I wrote my body responded
to economic crises it went to my it was
it acted as though when I saw a stock
ticker and it had a red down arrow that
the stock market had lost money
my body would respond so over
dramatically it was as though somebody
had a hatchet and they were coming right
for me
and I remember I used to laugh
because I felt so out of control that a
couple of folks in a couple of banks
could take everything from me and I was
doing everything right in my home I felt
very very powerless does that make sense
and then after counseling and working
and building a non-anxious life over the
last five to six to ten years
now we're in a recession heading towards
a deeper recession
my body hasn't taken off one time
meaning I've been frustrated and annoyed
and I'm heartbroken when I have to can't
buy bacon because the bacon prices are
so expensive and I got to choose between
bacon and bread
but I'm not spit staying up at you know
until 2 A.M and then waking up again at
3 30 a.m on high alert all the time and
I can't talk to my kids I'm gonna I'm
like a taser
so I'm I'm Healed
I'm still worrying about it I'm still
frustrated by it but my body didn't go
to war and your body goes to shutdown
and so it's you will know when you're
able to when your husband says hey is
tonight a good sex night and you say
No not tonight but I would love to just
snuggle on the couch and hold hold you
tight for a while watch a show and when
you say those words your heart doesn't
start being really fast you're not
washed over in shame and frustration and
you're able to own your needs in that
moment
does that make sense
yeah so it happens like that for a while
so what I want you to do is to start
really paying close attention when you
feel the cycle starting
what is different what is happening in
your life is your diet different are you
sleeping differently is your work
schedule or your husband's work
schedules or holiday coming up what is
it in the environment that starts to
kick that cycle up again
okay and I wanted I just want to be
really specific about track and that
kind of stuff even if it's going to get
a 99 cent Journal at Walmart
and then when it comes to sex and
intimacy I want you really to remember
this this is from Emily nagoski who if
you haven't uh I used to talk about the
book all the time I haven't in a while
um I recommend anybody who's having
conversations in their home
um like they're you know just a married
couple sitting there talking about how
they want to improve their sex life or
change their sex life there's a book
called come as you are that Emily
nigotsky wrote It's a masterpiece it's
incredible
um she was the first person I ever heard
so eloquently put
um outside of like nerd science journals
that there's no such thing as a sex
drive that's not real
that one person has more of a sex drive
and one person has less of a sex drive
and women's sex drive is just men's sex
drive light that's not true really
sexual desire is a series of of gas
pedals and breaks
and the goal is how can we work together
you and your husband
to
take off as many breaks as possible and
make the environment more gas pedals
what that means is you're not just
focusing on what gets you off in the
bedroom or what you will or won't do in
the bedroom
it's more about how do we create a
context in our home in our life cycle so
that sex becomes a place that we want to
run to
that becomes a great escape not another
chore so what I mean by that is like is
it a clean home is it
um all the dishes are done is it flirty
notes throughout the day is it the oil
changed people who've had
um sexual trauma in their past often
smells are really intense and so maybe
it's no cologne or you got to brush your
teeth or it's easy to take a shower
first whatever the things are
um you don't feel good about your bodies
dim the lights whatever the thing is
or the things are we're going to create
a world where
sex can happen
not we're going to try to force uh we're
gonna try to force a game of baseball in
the middle of a winter storm no dude
let's create a world where baseball
sounds like it's a great idea does that
make sense
yeah yeah it does that can be a ton of
fun
for you and your husband to dream about
how do we create an environment that
that makes this that there's no breaks
and it's all gas pedals and then we're
going to put sex on the calendar how
many little kids do you have
three good gosh yes you have to put on
the calendar and let me tell you Bethany
nobody wants to do that nobody wants to
put sex on the calendar
I've never seen a Hollywood movie where
they're like hi hi
next Tuesday 4 15 p.m that has never
happened it's always like
Titanic and there's the car and then
there's like the handprint on the wall
and it's this passion and I'm gonna die
for you none of that's real
you got three little kids you got to put
on the calendar
and let's let's set a goal two times a
week
five times a week 17 times I'm just
kidding 17 times that's a lot if that's
safe that's how y'all roll that's how
you roll that's a lot but let's let's
put on the calendar and let's talk about
it let's talk about it
what would a world of nothing but gas
pedals in your home be and how can your
husband honor you and help make that
happen and for him what's a world of gas
pedals
not of just breaks of I don't like this
I don't like this no dude this what if
this was the way our life was
and then we were very intentional about
we're gonna have sex on these days at
these times and I'm gonna help with
bedtime I'm gonna help with this I'm
gonna help with this we're gonna create
this context and you're gonna do the
hard work of tracking this cycle so that
when it starts heading south you know
oh it's when I eat this and do this and
talk to them and don't take care of this
or it's when the weather gets like this
or it's possibly hormonal I need to work
with my doctor
that's where we're gonna start pulling
that apart we're going to track it and
then we're going to teach our body over
time
that there's a different way to respond
to some of these stressors you're on the
right path Bethany and be really
gracious with yourself you got three
little ones
you're in Indiana it's cold be nice to
Bethany be nice to Bethany we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode's sponsor betterhelp
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is
life-changing stuff but I'll be honest
it's not easy these are new skills that
we all have to learn and therapy is a
great place to practice these new skills
and that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
what up what up we're back it's time for
facts are your friends
[Music]
been in his bell bottom rock music
Epiphone Flying V plugged into a fuzz
box
some Marlboro Reds way to go he's
looking at me like
do what you know Hyrule that's exactly
um all right so
I need to make this abundantly clear on
the front end of this facts of your
friends
I this is not a conversation about
judgment this is not a conversation
about me
um casting blame or Stones I know
there's a lot to be said about what
we're going to talk about for the next
few minutes so
um I've learned this the hard way on
social media I can say something like
hey moms or dads don't yell at your kids
and some of you hear that and you go
um you're right I need to not do that
but some of you immediately get
triggered and you go oh yeah well Dad's
and husbands [ __ ] like whoever I'm not
talking to they need to stop you're
right so this is one of those topics
that the moment I say it you're gonna
either go not me or you don't even know
what I'm dealing with or I'm such a
loser or some of you are really really
underwater with this issue and so I want
to be as gentle as possible and be
honest be honest
and
This Is Us just sitting down having a
chit chat over a card table okay so just
think of it um there's not me talking at
talking down to you is me talking with
you okay I want to talk about drinking
alcohol
um here's here is
um
why this became an issue with me
um I
rarely drink I just don't like it that
much um I'll have one drink here there
um
it's really really rare that I have two
not because I have any judgment against
it whatever in fact there's times I wish
I did I just I just don't feel good I
just don't like it I don't feel good
um I just get bloaty and
um
but then I got this woop strap and I
noticed even when I would have one glass
of wine if it had one beer or one like
one of these fancy Bourbons one of my
colleagues has
my sleep would flush itself down the
toilet it was it was so disregulated I
couldn't believe it and then I started
asking my other friends here at the
office who also had whoops and we were
comparing data and talking about it
because it was a relatively new product
at the time this is a couple years ago
and it has happened to everybody
and what was interesting is all of us
were quietly on our own worlds
essentially just quitting drinking for
one reason it screwed up our sleep so
bad that we could go to bed at the exact
same time and wake up at the exact same
time but our sleep was so screwed up
um and so then my wife got it and she
noticed it right
and then in short order it was one of
those huh oh yeah
our dinner bills when we would go out to
eat
the bill was so much less
and then grocery bills were so much less
and then it thinking about hey do we
need to Uber here or do we all that
stuff just kind of shifted and so I saw
what happened in my personal life
things just got
um less expensive less burdensome and my
sleep was better
and so I began wondering like why why
was I having one or two drinks like what
what was that getting me and that
started me down a rabbit hole of the
literature and I was going to go through
all the literature and stuff listen
um Andy huberman Andrew huberman over um
at The huberman Lab podcast you I'm
recommending you go find it
um after you know the show go find it he
does a two hour plus two and a half hour
master class on alcohol
all of the research what it does in your
brain which hormones and brain chemicals
it affects
he really does his best to find some
redeeming quality I'll be a little more
there's just very little redeeming
quality it just messes up most of your
body ethanol is a poison I wish it was
another thing but it's a poison
and so then Kelly sent me this article
the other day
um that was published by um the AP News
post-pandemic the rate of deaths that
can directly be attributed to alcohol
Who Rose nearly 30 percent in the U.S
during the first year of covet
um
the rates have continued to be up net
over what they've ever been
um
the rate of such death has been
increasing in two decades before the
pandemic by seven percent or less each
year
in 2020 they Rose 26 percent
it's the highest rate recorded at least
40 years
such deaths are two and a half times
more common in men than in women but
both Rose in 2020 the study found and
there's been a couple of great articles
and even a remarkable book I'll link to
it in the show notes the um the titles
just left me here
um
about alcohol consumption in women
and how the cool thing for women became
oh yeah she drinks beer or she drinks
whiskey or drinks Bourbon and that was a
way that everybody felt women were
getting a seat at the table
but there was a particular pressure
among women to oh yeah I can drink this
or this and it was a it was a part of a
overall power play part of a move
and women are paying a toll with their
physical and psychological health
and then there's the whole uh wine
Wednesday or wine in Wednesday or what's
it called what's it called Kelly
there's wine Wednesday There's so so
much around it's a stay-at-home mom
culture
day drinking yeah yeah you can buy cute
little shirts you know yeah Rose all day
and all that stuff and you notice like
you should go to Target or go to any of
these little Boutique shops or Walmart
it's all like sweatshirts and little
towels and little things just about how
fun day drinking is or because I have to
do it it's my only way to get through my
life and then I I noticed it when Mad
Men came out but it just all across the
country office complexes man everybody
started drinking more they start
drinking more and I don't know if it's
because it looked cool I don't know if
that's the show I just I just noticed a
non-scientific correlation between the
two there's nothing causal about it
everybody's just drinking more
a lot
um
and then there's these uh Jam of the
Journal of American Medical Association
they looked at a wider range of deaths
linked to drinking so there's death
during by people who just drink
themselves to death right
but then there's motor vehicle accidents
suicides
um often suest people who are
um considering Dying by Suicide will
drink enough to take their inhibition
away
and it leaves them with no breaks on a
forever decision Falls cancers
pancreatic cancer liver cancer and other
things
so there's
thousands and thousands and tens and
tens and tens of thousands of deaths are
from drinking too much over a long
period of time and tens and tens and
tens and tens of thousands of deaths are
tied to acute intoxication I fell down I
got in a wreck I died by Suicide
whatever it happens to be
and then there's obviously
chronic dangers such as high blood
pressure and stroke and heart disease
and liver cancer all this kind of stuff
so here's all I want oh to say today in
today's facts to your friends it's a new
year
as I've had this conversation with more
and more people across the country it's
particularly with moms and with business
owners and um and then more and more
with police officers military folks dads
uh it's running the gamut okay
I want you to be very intentional about
examining or re-examining the role
alcohol plays in your life
here's where that's really important
I uh used to pass out a survey to all my
incoming students particularly like I
did at the law school I did it at a
couple other places but it was just a
social norming survey
what's your drug use what your alcohol
use um what's your sexual habits I
wanted it to get a snapshot of what the
student incoming student body thought
about the world how they responded to
the world and I would always read these
statistics to the students and what was
always fascinating is
the students thought 95 of people got
drunk once a week
but the self-reported data was actually
65 percent of people got drunk once a
week so they were off by a chunk right
so I would read those and and the point
was hey if you think everybody's getting
drunk all the time the reality is
they're not if you think everybody's
having a glass of wine at 11 30 in the
morning just because the baby won't stop
screaming or because your boss is
kicking your butt they're not actually
not and it's this weird self-fulfilling
prophecy
I always remember the statistic that
that broke my heart and would silence
the room and it was 80 to 90 sometimes
mid to high 90s ninety percent of people
drank to felt feel more sexy drank to
facilitate engagement and sexual
behaviors
and every time I told the entire
Auditorium the entire theater
if you have to
drink
in order to be with somebody
that is a way you are overriding your
body's innate systems
to do something your body is telling you
it doesn't want to do
and the same can be said for going out
for feeling sexy for having hard
conversations for having fun for going
to sleep
if you are drinking to
override your body's signaling system
that sleep is scary that there's too
much chaos going on in your life that
your partner isn't safe that your work
environment is a mess that you are
uncomfortable being around people those
are individual things that you can work
on with a counselor that you can work on
with a community of friends that you can
work on with a journal some of those
things
but when you drink to cover up parts of
your life just so you can endure it
man
I just want you to hear me say your
life's worth more than that
and I would rather have a season of
discomfort getting to the bottom of why
does my body
tense up when I'm around you because
we're married let's get to the bottom of
that let's just don't have three or four
drinks just so we can have sex once a
week
let's don't do that
now if it's a part of if it's a I'm not
going to tell you to not drink okay I'm
not going to tell you to not enjoy your
life to not go have fun all that kind of
stuff
um I just want you to be conscious about
how and when you're where you're using
alcohol
also
if you are struggling with an alcohol
addiction
let this be the Year let this be the
podcast let this be the minute that you
Push pause on this show and you call
somebody and you say I need help
day one
or that you get out your phone and find
the next meeting and you're there
sitting in the back row looking around
wide-eyed but you're there
let this be the year that we're done
poisoning our bodies and our
relationships in our mind and we say
we're going to engage life and it's
going to be hell on Earth especially at
the beginning
but you are worth that
you're worth that
so again
it's not about judgment this is about
y'all just my friends
it's not about you won't see me with a
drink someday you probably will
um it's about being very conscious of
what is this drink doing for me and more
importantly what do I need this
and if I don't need it why am I doing it
why am I doing
the alcohol death is growing in the U.S
and it's up to us to change that some of
that's going to be most of that's going
to be us deciding let's build a life
worth living
let's build a life
let's build a non-anxious life that we
don't have to run and hide from
let's get people in our lives let's
create a context where we can walk right
through the middle of it
so that's back to your friends
examine your relationship with alcohol
[Music]
you're worth it we'll be right back
all right let's go to uh Christine in
San Antonio home of the Alamo and PeeWee
Herman's bike in the basement what's up
Christine
hey Dr D how are you partying man what
are you up to I am in crisis management
mode but I am okay oh man I got you I
don't know if I got you another thing I
just like to declare that you do that's
why I'm calling so what's up what's up
uh first of all I just wanted to tell
you thank you for doing the Lord's work
uh I do miss your horse noises um we
unfortunately missed you in San Antonio
and your Christmas edition of your
questions for humans yeah so hopefully
we'll get to do both soon I know I I saw
it and I meant to order it and then I I
waited for the Black Friday sale they
were all gone so I think there's a deck
over there on the customer service
counter if it's there Jenna will get it
and mail it to you okay
you're the sweetest you'll get it you'll
get it after Christmas
but if they're sold out if they're sold
out they're gone already
good gosh okay never mind they're sold
out they're just they're they're nodding
that's all right my bad I appreciate it
all right hopefully we get to see you
next time you're in the area so awesome
I got an event I got an event coming up
in Austin in a few weeks uh maybe y'all
can come up uh then
yeah yeah we'll definitely try to make
that happen
um so my old question was and if you
give me I'm sorry I have it written down
two minutes I will get through this
Spiel and then I'm all yours all right
spill it up
thank you my old question was in my
situation does love look like sending a
Christmas card or not however things
have changed my younger sister went off
the charts she's breaking ceilings and
all the wrong kinds of way our family
values growing up did not reflect this
Behavior a few months ago she blindsided
our family and acted erratically left
her own home and lived with friends that
no one knew she had she's found to be
using drugs then last night she reaches
out and asks us for help so my new
questions are
what kind of mental health professional
can I reach out that can give her the
help she needs someone who can actually
determine facts from fiction as she is a
very convincing liar and could be hiding
truths out of fear of repercussion from
the people she's staying with two is
there a way to get a mandatory mental
health evaluation possibly while a
medical exam is being conducted is that
something medical professionals can
enforce because we've tried to get
assistance from local PD from multiple
occasions and we've been met every time
with a lot of resistance and no help
um
and then overall if you have any other
recommendations we I'm an open book uh
the situation my sister cut off the
family she became involved in suspected
criminal activity started using meth a
few months ago she made it painfully
clear that she wants nothing to do with
any biological family or lifetime
friends she recently recently gave a
permanent custody of her son it was a
fight to protect him but we did it when
it comes to her she's an adult who's
very sick and needs help but the law is
not helping us at all
I'm done always respect you so first I
just want to say um
I'm sorry so I can tell that you love
your sister
yeah
and Christmas is gonna have a big hole
in it this year
yeah it's been hard
and she's probably going in the family
who's helping I'm the emergency
management manager
who gave you that role
I was put in that role
did you naturally fall into it and maybe
he listens to me okay
I I would say I rise to the occasion
because that's I would suggest you
resign your position immediately
okay
okay
um
the first thing out of the gate I want
you to really work on
and this might be writing a letter to
your sister that you're never gonna send
this might be your 12 year old
self-writing a letter to your 10 year
old sister however old the age
difference is between the two of you
but there won't be any healing until you
switch off
your judgment switch
and you switch on your I'm with you
switch
okay okay everything in your letter from
about I mean not from your letter from
what you just read
everything from this isn't the family
values that she knows and she's doing
this and she's doing this and I'm trying
to do this
says it's from a position of
she's a puppy who keeps peeing in the
floor and I don't know how to get her to
stop and I'm her owner and I understand
how somebody who is mapped out of their
minds and they're abandoning their
family and their children it feels like
like it feels like the pipes just burst
in the house
but if you bring that chaotic energy to
somebody who's struggling with addiction
like this
that that energy is jet fuel for
the problematic behaviors
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
research about it and it gets a lot of
bad press
um
but healing from addiction healing from
drug use Almost Never
comes from a like upping the aggression
ante
okay
that's number one so I want you to
take off any sort of superiority maybe
begin to ask yourself the question what
in bloody hell happened in her life
things you know about things you may not
know about
that this is how she's got to get
through her day
okay what in the world happened
and my guess is you probably know some
of it and my guess is there may be a
couple of things that
your eyes would pop out of your head if
you heard
yeah either or right all that to say is
it just changes the posture
to get your butt in here to
I really love it if you came home that's
two different propositions right so
that's number one number two I wanna I
know you're right in the middle of it
and this is hard I want to back out and
respect what the police officers are
doing is even though it's super
frustrating
the whole our entire system is based on
not taking away somebody's civil rights
and so the threshold to look at another
adult and say you have lost the
privilege of a of being in control of
your own life that's the premise of this
country however screwed up we've gotten
it and make no mistake about that we've
screwed that up for years and years and
years but that's one of the foundational
premises and so to get a government
agency to take away agency from another
adult is very very hard that bar is very
high and usually it's harm to self or
others
and there is a pretty significant
bifurcation between mental health if you
have schizophrenia versus you're an
addict
our approach to Addiction in this
country is still very punitive you are
breaking the rules
versus you're sick with a disease
yeah see what I'm saying and so if your
sister had schizophrenia
um or you might have a better chance of
getting medical power of attorney over
her
um or having her some sort of um
involuntary Commitment if she was uh you
know
experiencing suicide ideation or
anything like that having a sister who's
doing meth it's gonna be very very hard
outside of she gets busted with meth and
she goes to jail and has to clean up
there
Yeah we actually tried that and um the
police were not helpful at all we're
just trying to get a removed from
the environment that she's choosing to
be chose homelessness for the last 48
hours
um completely hungry and starving and
frantic and why is she why is she making
that choice is it because she's crazy is
she still high she's still she's still
not in her right mind
I suspect she's not in her right mind
and we called police and I officially
requested a medical email on site and
they just said well there's not enough
indicators here in your family for not
helping her like taking her in and stuff
Okay so what what does it look like if
you do bring her home
um will she come home okay I know I mean
she may or may not
um I don't trust that she won't stab me
or
something like that what in your world
has have given you inclination that she
is violent
and she's already made a made of police
report against my brother for beating
her and our family for beating her when
nobody has that discharges obviously got
dropped
um but I just can't trust her in my own
home because she's happy to create false
CPS reports police reports you name it
okay
[Music]
um
and the few times this situation has
happened in my life not with family
members but with people who I love close
enough that I consider them family
um
I have resorted to two things and it's
very very difficult number one writing a
letter
and the reason I write a letter so they
can hold on to it
and it has amazed me how people have
hung on to those things when they
literally hang on to nothing else to
hang on to these and the letter starts
with I love you and I miss you that's
how the letter starts yeah
and
when you're ready
I'll be here
yeah and that the second thing is is you
got to open your hands and let go
because she is clearly communicating I'm
an adult and I do not want you in my
life
unless it's convenient
yeah
exactly
and so if she's holding something that
says when you are ready
because helping somebody who is abusing
drugs helping somebody who's struggling
with alcohol and takes somebody who's
struggling with any number of things
is right and good and hard and those
people don't have a right to be abusive
to you
right so it's easy for the cops whatever
police officer said well you're just
scumbag family for not taking them in
yeah she doesn't have a right to come to
your house and verbally harass you or to
make fake reports or to beat you all up
or anything like that
so when she's ready it might be that you
will pay the first week of or you will
get with the family and the y'all will
have the funds to make sure she can go
to rehab because that's where she's her
first Stop's got to be at a 30-day
inpatient treatment facility
yeah we're doing that right now
um I've got some treatment facilities
lined up and I'm hoping I can convince
her I mean obviously I can't talk her
into going if she doesn't want to go but
I'm going to present the options and if
she says yes take her there yeah I'll
drop you off
yep and I'll be the first one picking
you up cheering you when when um I'm
allowed to but I can't make you do this
I can't I can't I'm not your parent I'm
just someone who loves you and it's
killing me to watch what's happening who
got custody of of of her child
uh my parents okay
um
I'm sorry
me too
I'm gonna tell you one more thing that
um is also hard to hear
you're also still allowed to enjoy your
Christmas
yeah
and every time you smile or laugh or put
joy in the world or over tip a waiter or
a waitress at some restaurant
you're injecting Beauty into the world
you're not taking you're not violating
something you're not ruining something
you know what I mean
mm-hmm
and so I would appreciate that I would
do the best I could to laugh as much as
I can as hard as it's going to be to
ghosts over serve and over give and have
fun with my kids I would try my best as
hard as it's going to be
because the alternative is is she's
having a miserable Christmas holiday
because she's hurting so badly and she's
making some tough tough dangerous scary
bad choices
and
I guess I'm just going to choose to be
miserable too see how that didn't help
anything
no and we've been as a family this has
been a shared family Trauma from the
start we've been very intentional about
still celebrating our ups and downs
there's been a lot to celebrate it's
just with a lot of up you know it's a
roller coaster yeah
um
I would if I was you to go back to my
original thing I would resign my
position as the family
um crisis responder
it's not your job it's Mom and Dad's job
and if they choose to not do that cool
I'll choose to be a sister
but I'm not going to be the person that
coordinates all the phone calls and all
the stuff and all this because y'all
don't because what you're doing is hey
you're getting your self-esteem from
being the hero and that's a dangerous
place to be the second thing is is
you're trying to control the behaviors
of a whole bunch of different adults and
it's exhausting and it doesn't work
yes and they all end up resenting you
and it's not even you that did it but
they resent you
right
yeah oh God Christine's calling again oh
great Christine gonna be asking us for
just quit and I would use that language
hey family I'm resigning from this this
uh crisis responder that's not my job my
job is to be your daughter my daughter
my job is to be uh her sister
those are my two jobs that's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do them really really
well
and uh then I'm gonna move on from there
and you're gonna have to heal from hero
complex because you can't save all these
adults
the only person on planet Earth you can
control unfortunately is you
let's make sure you're well and you're
whole
we're down from the position of judgment
we're not we are with
then when she's ready she'll know you're
safe
yeah that's the worst I'm so so sorry
don't quit fighting for it
don't quit fighting for it but don't
lose yourself in the process we'll be
right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
off the License to Ill record
The Great and Wonderful Beastie Boys
Brass Monkey
goes like this I got this dance there's
more than real that's more than real
drink Brass Monkey here's how you feel
put your left leg down your right leg up
and you tilt your head back let's finish
the cup MCA with a bottle and drocks the
can adrock gets nice with Charlie Chan
we've offered Moet we don't mind shivas
shivas
wherever we go we bring the monkey with
us
and rock drinks three Mike T ISD Double
R foots the bill most definitely ah man
I drink Brass Monkey and I rock well got
a castle in Brooklyn
it's where I dwell
I'll see y'all soon everybody make good
choices
[Music]